today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i put the link right below
this video
alright welcome to the program much to
discuss so let's get right into it
donald trump is starting to lose support
with
white voters this is the one demographic
group that at least
until recently donald trump still had
supporting him we looked at a cross
section of polling a couple of weeks ago
and we saw joe biden is winning the
black vote
joe biden is winning the latino vote joe
biden is winning women
joe biden is winning the college
educated however you want to slice and
dice it
donald trump's resistance line
demographically was
white voters particularly white men
particularly
uneducated white voters but
unfortunately
for trump good for the world donald
trump has lost
some ground with white voters relative
to 2016
and it could be could right depends on
who votes depends on whether votes are
counted properly
this could be trump's undoing in
november let's look at some numbers
in 2016 donald trump won
white voters in minnesota by seven and
right now trump is losing white voters
in minnesota by two
that's a nine point swing against
trump among minnesota white voters
in wisconsin trump won uneducated white
women by 16
in the last election and he's now losing
uneducated white women
by nine that's a 25 point swing
against donald trump in pennsylvania
where we have a lot of data on this
biden and trump are tied among white
voters
trump won white voters in pennsylvania
in 2016.
but if you slice it down even further
donald trump is struggling with
pennsylvania
suburban white voters and this has been
a gradual shift
first it was the college-educated white
voters that started to move away from
donald trump
now you're even seeing
non-college-educated white voters
starting to move away from donald trump
now
to be fair and to be thorough there are
some other slices where trump has
improved since 2016. so
if you look at pennsylvania suburban
white women
trump's doing okay with them voters who
disliked both trump and hillary in 2016
trump is doing okay with them but these
are potentially significant problems for
donald trump
again with a major caveat if
everyone's votes are counted now what's
fascinating about this
is that as white voters have moved away
from donald trump
trump has been more and more
aggressively throwing out sort of like
red meat for white voters lately talking
about
saving the suburbs which has very
racially coded
language he's even lamented voters who
have to live around
refugees and immigrants in various parts
of the country he did that at a recent
i think it was pennsylvania and north
carolina rallies if i recall correctly
but regardless white voters slowly
moving away from donald trump now will
it be enough to make a difference
in the final calculation we don't know
we don't know
um the the the strategies that trump has
left
to actually win are dwindling one such
strategy that trump was hoping for was
announce a vaccine in october and
unfortunately for him two days ago the
federal
drug administration the fda said that
they are making uh putting in place
stricter guidelines
to approve a vaccine via an emergency
use authorization
that's bad for trump he's unlikely to
get whatever boost he might have gotten
from a vaccine announcement will trump
push for some emergency stimulus checks
right before the election i don't know
that he even has the time i really don't
particularly with the senate
uh going into recess and just what is it
about 21 days really just three weeks
so i don't know what trump can do and my
sense particularly from donald trump's
recent refusal to commit to a peaceful
transition of power if he loses
from donald trump's recent uh revelation
that we got
about a strategy to try to mess with the
electors
if he were to lose my instinct is
trump's focus is no longer on
actually winning it's on having a
strategy to
plausibly claim the results were rigged
and to snatch
the victory from joe biden if joe biden
were to win this is one of those stories
that is only shocking if you're not
paying attention
donald trump reportedly said jews
here we go now jews are only
in it for themselves after a recent call
with jewish leaders
according to a new report is anybody
really shocked by this and i know people
will often come back and say
but trump's son-in-law is jewish trump
can't be anti-semitic oh but trump's
daughter converted to judaism oh but
trump's grandkids are jewish oh but
trump
moved the embassy from tel aviv to
jerusalem i even got a call about this
actually on on voicemail
earlier this week which i played for you
this is why all of that stuff is
is meaningless by every reasonable
estimation
donald trump has the same tired old
stereotypical views about jewish folks
about black folks about hispanic folks
it's all the same stuff so
you know yes jews are only in it for
themselves this is what trump reportedly
said in front of officials
according to a new report from the
washington post more than two dozen
current and former administration
officials told the washington post about
trump's private views on race
and described racist remarks that he has
made while in office
it's a widely sourced story more than 20
people talking about what they observed
the washington post writes that the
president's characterization of jews
happened after he got off the phone with
jewish
lawmakers during a conference call last
week
with american jews trump reportedly said
we love your country referring to israel
as if
israel is the country of american jews
which is another trope
he also told an audience of jewish
americans that
israeli leader benjamin netanyahu is
your prime minister which is wild
trump has previously called jews who are
democrats
disloyal and these are all common
anti-semitic tropes that have been
around for a long time
the idea that american jews hold some
greater allegiance to israel or a dual
loyalty
many of these are folks who have never
even been to israel
that uh they are more loyal to israel
than their
actual countries of birth or of
residence
and at this point the surprising thing
is not that trump is accused
of saying this stuff the surprising
thing is that anybody's shocked by it
now let's let's uh dig in a little more
into one aspect of this
this idea this trope of jews are in it
for themselves
most people are generally speaking
concerned with their own well-being look
at republicans right now with the
supreme court
are they in this for anybody but
themselves and their own
the the preservation of their ideology
this is the absurdity
of some of these tropes that are stuck
to one group
oh you know the trope of the jews love
money they're in it for the money
do do white people hate money do white
people not care about money
black people don't care about money
seeks they're against money
women hate money middle-aged people hate
money
that's part of the absurdity of some of
these tropes that
some of them are so vague and
meaningless
that it actually boggles the mind how
people can
seriously consider them assessments of a
particular group it's absurd
and trump of course is able to so
casually go
from one racist or xenophobic trope to
the next
almost second nature to him it it really
seems to come very naturally to him
now do i tell you this because i think
it's going to you know alter the
election results
no the people that are supporting trump
at this point
are not going to be dissuaded because
trump said uh jews are only in it for
themselves
the people who are already voting for
trump at this late stage in the game
are not going to be dissuaded because of
trump's racially tinged message that joe
biden
will destroy the suburbs by looking at
how housing policy can have
racial repercussions these people are
with trump no matter what the reason i i
tell you about this
is to just remind you that very often
we just have to believe what's plain as
day if it looks like a duck
if it sounds like a duck if it walks
like a duck
mostly it's a duck that's really the
concept of occam's razor
from the scientific world and that is
exactly what we are seeing here with
donald trump no surprise whatsoever
he is exactly what he appears to be uh
we have a fantastic program for you
today we are going to talk about
what is the risk to roe v wade if indeed
donald trump replaces ruth bader
ginsburg
with a handmaid's tale like uh ideologue
from the american right we are also
going to talk about
i mentioned undecided voters and decided
voters
who are the undecided voters right now
we have actually have some data about
them and we're going to talk about that
a little bit later
uh we're going to take some of your
phone calls and we have so much going on
next week not only do we have a week of
shows and a week of bonus shows
if you are a member which you should be
at joinedpakman.com
we have the first presidential debate
biden vs trump tuesday night
join me on your choice youtube twitch or
facebook whichever you like best
join me at 8 30 pm eastern 5 30 p.m
pacific for the first
biden vs trump debate it's going to be
wild
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i've put the link
right underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
don't forget that membership is the
number one way
the david pakman show is funded grab a
membership and get all of the associated
benefits including the daily bonus show
world famous uh by signing up at
joinpakman.com
let's go to um let's go to the phones
at 617-830-4750
starting today with our caller from the
980 area code caller from 980
what's your name and where are you
calling from today
hello yes that's you sweet hi
uh my name is stan i'm calling from
north carolina
what's going on um yes so
i just have one kind of like one long
question so like
um so like i know i've noticed that you
few other like uh like
left independence voices on youtube
have like made this claim about like
vote out donald trump
yes fine and then we'll and then like
we'll push
biden left or we'll hold him accountable
and like i just don't get that i kind of
see that as basically
a big as a big of a lie as like
oh biden's going to be the next fb fdr
or whatever just because like what level
of
protesting organizing is going to push
biden left that 200 dead americans
haven't pushed him left that a millions
of unemployed
americans who've also lost their health
care hasn't pushed him left
that like months of protesting against
police brutality
has it pushed him left and we still got
the cop for a vp
well hold on a second but let's let's
examine that if we can
if you compare joe biden today to joe
biden even five years ago
nevermind 10 or 15 or 47 as donald trump
likes to do
the move to the left has been dramatic
has it not i mean you look at
biden's position today on health care
which
includes you know again it's not single
payer but it's
public option open to lowering the
medicare
age by five or ten years which would
give millions of people access
subsidizing to a higher level of income
right all these
we're talking about tens of millions of
more people getting health care you look
at
cannabis just coming out and saying full
federal decriminalization
of cannabis like he's already moved to
the left and i think what we mean when
we say we continue to push
is when we look at the house and senate
the more
left those legislative bodies go the
more progressive will be the bills that
get put on president joe biden's desk it
all seems coherent to me
but i i still just don't quite see it
just
that's like you don't see it okay but
you said it was one of the biggest lies
you've heard that
who's lying who are the people lying
like you it may not happen and you may
not
be confident in it but i don't know that
it's a big lie
it's just not like let's say like you or
perhaps like maybe
jenkins the young turks or david dole
from rational national like a few of
these will say
push by and left i'm just kind of
curious what exactly does that look like
just because like millions of people
lost their health insurance 200 000 dead
americans
and buying still won't endorse a full
like medicare for all universal health
care plan
and even then like on the public option
front i'm pretty sure there's like
a political article that says that they
might not even push a public option just
to get
like some brownie points for working
with republicans
okay well that's that's speculative and
we have to see if that happens but i i
just i think i just disagree with with
the framing i mean it's
you know we have to understand what what
do we have control over and what do we
not have control over
different people had different
preferences in the primary biden's the
nominee now the options
we we now now that's beyond our control
now the option is who's president trump
or biden
we can vote if biden is president then
what can we control we can't go back and
make bernie the president
so all we can do is lobby and elect the
most progressive possible
senate and house like we just we have to
focus on what we can do and i just don't
see sort of the point of
speculating that people are lying about
pushing biden left it's
what can we do and that is actually
something that
is a coherent cohesive strategy if joe
biden becomes president
no so it's not like people will push him
it's not that like the lie is that
people will want to push them left
okay is it the idea of like
him being pushable to the last but the
last
10 years are evidence look at biden's po
look at biden's policy
on health care economics and
energy today and look at what he
was part of in terms of policy during
the obama administration i mean even in
the last
four years joe biden has been pulled
significantly to the left
like but didn't doesn't even hillary
clinton suggest
an even lower age for medicaid for
medicare
that may be but you look at the sum
total i mean look at the
look at the economic policy that joe
biden is proposing look at uncapping
social security tax
doing away with a lower rate for capital
gains
an alternative a minimum tax for
corporations like the
these are big things that hillary
clinton from what i recall was not even
talking about in 2016. listen i gotta
run because i've got a lot of people
holding but i think i would i would
maybe re rethink some of your ideas and
see if they're really passing the sniff
test
okay all right my friend thank you so
much appreciate the call
uh let's see let's go next to
let's go to our caller from the 774
who i have noted as a woman from
massachusetts
or rhode island does that make sense 774
do you know who that is
uh yeah is it me that is exactly you
what was your name for some reason we
didn't get it last time
uh jen jen okay what's on your mind jen
yeah
i was living on the the border so i
still have a mass number but
i'm actually in providence now okay
that's allowed um
now jen you're coming in so hot please
try to keep the phone just a little
further from your mouth and you'll be
able to
hear you much more perfectly all right
is this better oh my god that's so much
better thank you
okay thanks uh so do you know anyone who
worked um for the census this year as an
enumerator or anything
not personally but i've had them come to
my house
okay so i did i was an enumerator for
three weeks
and uh there might be some calls for
concern coming up in the next 10 years
with the results because this was a
complete mess
yes uh i did it 10 years ago and of
course it was a much you know different
political climate than what it is now
right but this was horrible they tried a
completely new system they tried doing
it all by smartphone
and it was constantly giving us errors
it would just drop
us from time to time it would send us to
completely wrong neighborhoods
uh and there were just a lot of people
who did not want to be counted or people
who you would answer the door and they
would be crying finding out a family
member just got covered
oh my god you were coming face to face
with the virus and like oh crap did they
have it did they breathe on me
you know things like that now let me ask
you this jen let me ask you this
when someone didn't want to be counted
what was their explanation why why would
they what did they say
a lot of times they would lie and claim
they did it online
or sent it through their mail the mail i
can understand with what's going on but
if they did it online it would have been
coming up a few people
did get flat out aggressive and said
they don't want trump knowing their
business
um that they don't think we need to know
also wow providence is a very uh
ethically diverse area a lot of hispanic
uh
residents and they thought that that uh
citizenship question would probably
be on there right right right right so
they were terrified that we were gonna
start asking them about that
and they didn't know that did that
didn't pass so a lot that's interesting
that's interesting because i previously
said once the citizenship
question was thrown out that the damage
may well have been done
merely by proposing it and that it may
not even get to people
that it was thrown out and it sounds
like you're saying that's exactly what
happened
yes we definitely had the repercussions
of that as soon as they talked about it
i just thought oh
man i wanted to do it this year it's
going to be a myth
and it was even worse than what we
expected do you think that you received
uh adequate training for doing this
during a pandemic or were you just kind
of thrown to the wolves
we were pretty much thrown at the walls
because they couldn't really do any
in-person training they had a few online
videos they had us watch
wow um but for the most part the phone
system would kind of walk you through it
but when it was constantly just kind of
tripping over itself
it was just causing more and more
problems and at one point they just
started dropping people because we had
too many like do not answers and things
like that where they're like yeah
your assigned neighborhoods have gone
stale we have no more need for you
goodbye
well i wish i could say 190
i i wish i could say what you were
telling me was surprising
but we've been talking about this for
the last four years that this is exactly
how the census was going to go and jen
it sounds like it's going exactly that
poorly
yeah so there's gonna be some bad
blowout from it in the next few years
you know all the results because there's
gonna be representatives that we're not
gonna get
school that we don't get here all
because you know all these
tens of thousands of people who were not
counted right right right
all right jen um thank you thank you for
letting us know what's going on i wish
you had better news
yeah thank you david you have a great
day all right you too take care there's
a
jen from the epicenter of the border
between massachusetts and rhode island
let's go to oh i want to go to john
from philly amigo dominicano john from
philly how are you today my friend
hey davey how are you sir good how are
you
good good uh i have a question for you
yeah i don't know if this has been
brought to you before
um why i am democrat
why do do democrats sometimes
in politics are so weak like
i don't know like i cannot explain like
week or bang over or you know i'm easily
bang over for
for the republican to do anything they
want
uh it seems to be like this is all
over every time because even when they
are not in power
yeah i mean when they are even in power
like when they tell the house the senate
the presidency even republicans can
screw them over for anything like and
they seem to be like
easily i don't know like
i don't know how i can explain no you're
you're explaining it beautifully
i don't have an answer for you i wish i
had so
here's the one thing i would say john
there's something to be said for
not stooping down to the level of the
right like i understand the concept of
the right to lacks morality
they are total hypocrites they'll do
whatever the hell they'll
say one thing in 2016 in order to
prevent a nominee to get on the court
and then they'll say something different
and like they have no morality
whatsoever
and there's something to be said about
not stooping to their level but you're
bringing up a good point which is at
some point don't you need to start
winning
correct like they i mean
it's always the right always screw them
over
all the time yes even we lodge it
you know the the right sometimes they
never have logic
and they they have they
they [ __ ] to to win anything filthy
you know yeah but the problem is you
know i do think that
the problem is if the left uses the
rights dirty tactics to win
aren't we as bad as they are in some
sense
i don't know i don't know the answer to
that yeah me neither
right but i share your concern i share
your concern and what's going on now
with the supreme court
is it's it's disgusting but it's also
totally predictable right
correct yeah yeah i agree
uh john are you voting in person by mail
what are you doing
i'm thinking to going to vote in person
okay we will see how
things going and will you try to do
early voting or november third you think
i don't know because in pennsylvania i
don't know when they open
right go and go in person i think it's
soon i think it's very soon
it's very soon okay i think but when
it's available i'm gonna
you know i'm gonna do it go ahead and do
it also as soon as i
can all right john i appreciate the
phone call
all right david you have a wonderful day
okay you too take care bye
there's uh john from philly originally
from the dr we love john
let's go next to our caller
from the 347 area code who's calling
today from three four seven
hey david uh my name is michael and
thanks for taking my call
um so i am a committed democrat
michael i'm sorry to have to interrupt
you you're gonna have to uh you're gonna
have to back away from the phone a
little or drop your voice down to a more
reasonable level because you're
you're i'm about to blow an eardrum oh
no
oh no okay um so i'm a committed
democrat
uh 66 years old native new yorker
and i have one major concern yes so
do you think that the democratic party
is
really really prepared with strategies
to deal with the red mirage right
okay let me explain what that is to
people so so red mirage is the idea that
because biden voters are much more
likely to vote absentee
that you could have states where it's
close where on election night
trump has a small lead and then in the
days that follow as the absentee ballots
are counted
joe biden takes a lead and the fear is
that in the intervening time donald
trump will use the lawyers we know he
has ready to go
to try to stop the counting of absentee
ballots or do other things
so your question was do i think
democrats are ready to deal with that
the answer is
no i think that they are partially ready
we did
get a report late last week that joe
biden and the democratic party
are getting numerous lawyers ready to
try to deal with this
but the the problem is that you
fundamentally have an advantage if
you're playing offense because you know
what the strategy is if you are playing
defense
in this case by definition you're at a
disadvantage
because you're playing defense against
what you believe they are going to try
but they may try things you're not
prepared for so i think that
on a scale of 1 to 10 the left is
probably at a five or six in terms of
being ready to deal with red mirage
okay so if i could go further with my
question
um you know how for example when
democratic candidates are preparing for
debate
yeah and what happened like for example
right now you have pete buddha judge
supposedly is helping
kamala harris and he's playing the role
of mike pence
right and what they're doing is they're
practicing and they're anticipating
like one anticipates chess moves sure
so if that's the approach so i would
like to
i would think that we would be needing
to do that
anticipating a variety of different
moves no doubt that we would have to
make because
as you correctly stated we're not going
to know exactly all the
all the things that trump will do and
yes they because they're on offense
you're absolutely right
but i'm just wondering is there anything
that any of us
could do i'm just an average citizen you
have a prominent position in
in the political world but i'm just
wondering is there anything that we that
can be done
to get the message across to uh
leading yeah the leaders of the
democratic party that they need to be
fully strategizing in every single way
possible to anticipate every possible
move
the republicans may make so
unfortunately i think on this one being
so close
to november if the democratic party
doesn't already know that they need to
be ready for this
i don't know that there's much we can do
i think what we can do is to make sure
that at the individual level people
understand for example
if you are in line to vote before polls
close you can vote
don't be tricked into being told you
can't vote right because this is how
they could
they could do effect turnout we need to
sort of inform people at the individual
level because we're only six five and a
half weeks out
at this point if the democratic party's
not ready for red mirage
it's over like there's nothing you or i
at this point can do sadly i hope that
they are ready i don't know if they are
yeah well hey my obviously my concern is
not alleviated but your answer is
absolutely right on the money as usual
thank you david so
anyway thanks for what you do you have a
great show and i just love your clarity
and your analysis
and you your contributions to the
political discussion is so valid so keep
doing what you're doing
and i wish you all the you know
continued success pleasure having you on
i really do appreciate the phone call
let's take a quick break if you are
holding and that's an
if um don't hang up because we're going
right back to the phones momentarily the
david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous
bonus show as well as commercial free
audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you forty percent vote
soon eighteen
back to the david pakman show let's get
back to the phones where folks are
eagerly awaiting
uh with questions and comments at
617-830-4750
let's go to our caller from the 405 area
code
uh is 405 northern california
uh hello yes that's you can you hear me
yes i can
okay um no 405 is actually an oklahoma
number
but uh my family moved from oklahoma to
virginia actually
and our area code is 276 i think but i
never changed my phone number beautiful
i never got it updated
um i just have two quick questions for
you they're not really
it's pretty complicated subject but uh
um i'm actually 16
so i can't vote yet very unfortunately
and i've been i just got introduced to
the political space
ever since the coronavirus you know hit
and
started ravaging the world and
everything so i was wondering
as a 16 year old how can i help
the democratic cause obviously since
it's not a guarantee whatsoever and
anything can happen and there's no
absolute
uh guarantee that we can win
right so listen in the immediate you
can't vote
but you can phone bank okay so you can
figure out do you want a phone bank
for joe biden do you want to phone bank
for some particular
senate race or house race so so i think
that's one area
i don't think there's any restrictions
on 16 year olds campaigning in other
ways so you can get in
correct me if i'm wrong but i believe
you can get involved in campaigns
uh in a variety of different ways i
would also remind you that
in the midterms that are just two years
away you will be able to vote by then
so certainly that you're you're very
very close
definitely plan on it yeah i definitely
plan on voting by then
um my second question well thank you for
the answer but my second question was
do you think my generation is going to
bring anything new to the table
because obviously the the entire
political spectrum right now is very
corrupt
uh everyone's just doing what they can
do the win and they don't actually care
about the average person
so do you think the millennial
generation and my generation will
actually change anything or do you think
it's just
just the kind of ongoing pattern that
will never end and we're just going to
be stuck in this
endless cycle so i think the answer is
yes we will you will if we and you
want to and if you look back in history
there's always been this idea
that whatever is the up up-and-coming
generation
they're lazy they're burnouts they're
not going to do it you know this was
said during
about the hippie movement in the 60s and
70s they're not going to do anything
except for the ones that went to vietnam
because they were drafted
they just want to hang out and smoke pot
and go to woodstock and all of this
stuff
it's been said about the millennial
generation it's been said about
uh some of the you know now younger than
millennials oh they're lazy and because
of they grew up with technology
and this and that listen every single
one of these generations
if we want to if they want to is going
to be able to change the system but it
comes down to
understanding that you need to get
involved and involved in a serious way
and if not then it'll just be more of
the same as you're
correctly pointing out yeah
well thank you so much for the feedback
i just wondered what your thoughts were
you've been
you've been this kind of voice of reason
i've been following your live streams
and stuff
i'm excited for the debates and
hopefully it doesn't completely
uh go wrong for joe biden i i hope he
wins and
thank you for being this voice of reason
in this time of chaos
thank you for calling in i'm so glad
that you're engaging in politics at a
young age and listen the debates could
go wrong for trump too don't
underestimate that possibility yeah that
too yeah
all right my friend thank you great to
hear from you um
let's go next continuing our tour of the
united states via phone
let's go to the eight five zero area
code
caller from eight five zero what's your
name and where are you calling from
hey david this is phillip and uh i'm
calling from mississippi i've got a
florida number though
what's going on well i've got two
questions first of all did you see the
news recently where trump actually
admitted his game plan as far as uh
the the supreme court pick and kind of
taken going to
the supreme court and arguing against
the mailing ballot
and trying to take over that way yep
absolutely so trump
trump has said he is counting on the
court system to help him
in november he says it's to prevent it
from being rigged
really it's too rigid and uh the federal
appeals courts could be a part of it
who knows depending on what happens the
supreme court could be a part of it
absolutely
right the second thing i wanted to
address is that um it
seems though the republicans the only
way they can get ahead is through
through cheating at least that that's
the kind of like what
conclusion i'm coming to i mean over the
last seven years as i'm sure you know
excuse me over the last seven elections
uh we've only had one republican
win by popular vote so this electoral
college and the gerrymandering
mentoring and and all the judges that uh
recently mcconnell was picking it seems
the whole game plan is to stay in power
through the
with the republicans to stay in power
just by trying to you know steal the
vote and oppress the vote
and if you look at you know you look at
polls and cnn and fox news and online
everybody leans left i mean all the
things that we want
all the things everybody is actually
voting for where voting is easy
is left-leaning policies but we don't
see that reflected in the white house
because the voting is just it's not
there that's not easy to vote so i
believe that
if we can ever start having a
conversation about making
voting a national holiday about actually
doing like australia perhaps where they
have a fine if you don't vote or
or having the day off and just make it
easier more accessible i think we could
finally go in one direction in this
country instead of back and forth
ridiculous stuff every four to eight
years and actually get somewhere
i don't think that's going to happen
unless we do something you know with the
supreme court which is kind of going to
be very difficult now at this point
well mandatory voting is kind of its own
question and i think that that's a
separate issue
but you've beautifully pointed out that
we have a system
that you know we talk abstractly about
checks and balances and all of this
stuff
but we have a system that in practice
allows
a center-left country to be a
run by right-wing
legislative bodies and and judicial
bodies because of the things you're
pointing out if you look at
gerrymandering you have a structural
disadvantage
for democrats when it comes to what
percentage of the vote do they need to
get in order to just have 50 percent
representation
you look at the senate the senate by
giving two senators to each state
dramatically overstates the power of
these
states with very few people that still
get
two senators and i think it was
something like there were enough
you could have the senators representing
only 17 percent of the population
uh decide that trump is getting
acquitted in terms of impeachment
because of that
imbalance and the fundamentally
undemocratic nature of the senate
you have the electoral college as you
point out wherein
you have a country that votes for
democrats many times
and many of those times a republican is
still elected president so you've
pointed out
many of the ways in which the country is
not really democratically run
and it is a major problem right and i
just don't feel like we're going to make
any consistent progress forward uh no
matter what we do in the next four to
eight years it could be undone it's
rents repeat we just keep going back and
forth and it's very difficult to make
consistent progress if we're not able to
lean in one direction
well i do think that if joe biden wins
and democrats take the senate you could
definitely undo
a bunch of the damage trump has done and
make some progress
but let's not put the cart before the
horse let's deal with november 1st and
then see where we are
right thanks for taking my call david
all right appreciate it thank you so
much
let's go next to our caller from the
832 area code who is calling today from
832 hello
yes it is who's this uh this is reuben
from
houston reuben from houston what's going
on
right so i had two questions and mostly
it's just to you know orient myself a
little better
or you know understand you know
expectations
so with uh with the death of the supreme
court justice uh
there's been a lot of uh alarm sounding
i'll say and i just i just want to know
like
it appears we won't be able to stop it
or you know we have very limited options
yeah but if if if
uh they do appoint a supreme court
justice
is it really i mean i know it's pretty
bad and it's a shame that it was
happening
but is it really um
that bad uh say if we
take the summit and um uh
you know get the president elected it's
still
pretty bad it's two different things
okay that's the thing
so so reuben it's two different things
the things that are bad about a six to
three conservative court
are different things than what a
democratic senate can prevent
and so for example if you get a 6-3
conservative supreme court
you'll start to see really strict
restrictions on abortion passed at the
state level which will be challenged
in local courts appealed to federal
courts
and ultimately to the supreme court and
the supreme court could
issue rulings which set new precedent
which dramatically clamps down
on abortion rights as an example that
has nothing to do with democrats taking
the senate you understand so we're
talking about
but taking the senate is of huge
importance
but the appointed for life
supreme court which could go 6-3
conservative
is a whole slate of problems that have
nothing to do with the senate
right right i mean i i i recognize that
it's just
it seems like i mean obviously
for it's just that we don't hear in the
media
when a supreme court decision really
affects anything
except for every once in a while i'm not
sure what else
they like you know i don't know that i
agree with that
i mean listen i think maybe people don't
pay attention but if you look over the
last years you know very important
rulings with regard to
obamacare commerce related rulings that
affect how business is done stuff about
business discrimination
really important things about corporate
power i mean i think people don't
necessarily understand how those
decisions link to their everyday lives
it's just it's just that you said you
you only mentioned the abortion and that
that is something that i
i'm pro-pro-choice but
uh it's just i guess i didn't think
about like
healthcare things like that yeah okay
uh so second question is um so i
i made the mistake of donating to like
um
presidential election campaigns like
like biden
i mean it's not really a mistake it's
just like now they're hounding me all
the time and
i'm getting ads for you know um
for donating to you know senators and
just people running against republicans
and i wanted to ask
is that actually helpful like how
how how much use is that
money gonna go towards uh you know
making the country a better place well
those are two questions
is donating helpful to get people
elected the candidate who raises more
money tends to win all else being equal
so yeah it does help people get elected
whether they will improve the country
once elected is a much more
detailed and deep question that probably
exceeds our time today but yes
that money does help get people elected
by the way i've never donated to anybody
and i get the same ads
so i don't know how much of it is just
everybody's getting ads right now
well yeah i mean i guess if you just
seem politically
involved right that happens okay
well uh thank you very much uh for your
answers uh
and i really i really do think
uh you're doing a good thing here thank
you i appreciate the call thank you so
much
terrific to hear from you we are going
to go to a break my apologies i was not
able to take every phone call
but i do the best i can quick break back
after this
the david pakman show at david
davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going
is through patreon where you can pledge
as little as
one dollar per month or as much as you
want
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
great perks and benefits as well read
about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
all right let's get into audience
questions for the week a lot of
questions about the supreme court ruth
bader ginsburg
and one of those questions i received
from many people in the last few days
is whether roe v wade is gone if donald
trump replaces ruth bader ginsburg um
it does seem i mean listen we're going
to see what happens but
uh it seems increasingly likely that
donald trump is going to be able to fill
that vacancy on the supreme court
whether they do it before election day i
don't know
but even if joe biden were to win on
november 3rd
it does maybe even more so if joe biden
were to win on november 3rd
it does seem that um there are going to
be enough votes
from republicans in the senate remember
you need 51 republicans have 53 and
only two senators have said they would
wait at least until after the election
we don't we don't know
if they would insist on waiting until
the inauguration it seems they're going
to have 51.
so one of the big questions is whether
roe v wade which is a landmark united
states
ruling on abortion would be
taken down by a six to three
conservative court which is what it
would be if donald trump replaces ruth
bader ginsburg
with a right-wing ideologue which he
certainly would do
if given the opportunity remember that
roe v wade is a ruling
that says states can't ban abortion
altogether
now they can almost ban it so we've seen
a whole bunch of different states
increase restrictions on any
medical provider that does abortions
restrict
who can get an abortion or what needs to
happen in order to get one and
sometimes these um restrictions are
challenged in court
and sometimes they go very high in in
the appeals process
and what is ultimately left to the
interpretation
of the supreme court when those appeals
get to the court
is whether they violate the
spirit of roe v wade so in practice the
way you
overturn roe v wade is by change
by creating new precedent a state would
issue some
very very strict ruling on abortion
and it would get appealed all the way up
to the supreme court and the supreme
court
might say this is okay if that were to
happen you have effectively by precedent
undone roe v wade and you would have
many things change in red states and
not very much would change in blue
states the reality is
that if roe v wade were effectively
overturned by by creating new precedent
states like massachusetts other blue
states are not likely to see any real
changes
to the availability and access to safe
abortions
the red states will get absolutely
crushed and this is another one of those
ways in which i've said before even
during the trump presidency
in blue states we are insulated
in many ways from the destructive effect
of a radical ideological reactionary
presidency
like that of donald trump so as is often
the case
the destruction brought forward by
republican policy and right-wing
ideology
will disproportionately hurt
right-wingers when you look at
trump trying to undo obamacare
in massachusetts we already have
something that predates obamacare called
romneycare
and it is the folks in places like
mississippi which has one of the worst
one of the worst three
health care systems in the country it is
those folks
who are disproportionately hurt by
donald trump doing things like
undoing the individual mandate on
obamacare
so that's a reality that if they're able
to do it
not a lot will change in blue states a
lot will change in red states
now does the republican party really
want
roe v wade overturned the reason i ask
is if they actually overturn it
it's conceivable that there will be
number one
significantly renewed enthusiasm against
republicans at the state level in order
to try to
legalize abortion in a lot of these
states that are likely to overturn it
and
the reality is that since roe v wade was
was issued as a decision it has been a
great fundraising tool for republicans
republicans raise
a ton of money by saying we've got to
overturn
roe v wade we need you to vote for this
person and that person and that person
from
low level positions all the way up to
the president
we need you to do it so we can get the
right people in power
to overturn roe v wade if they actually
do it
they no longer have that carrot to rile
up evangelical
voters i think that there is some merit
to that and i
question whether republicans really want
to overturn it
or whether they want to keep fighting
about overturning it because it allows
them to raise money
it's a question but is roe v wade in
danger
with a six to three court particularly
if donald trump gets re-elected
and particularly if we maintain a
republican senate yes
it is in danger what it will mean in
massachusetts is a different question
hey david you talk about undecided
voters
who the hell could possibly be undecided
right now
about trump versus biden i agree with
the sentiment i've
said before almost verbatim who the hell
could be undecided right now
only if you've not been paying attention
right could you be undecided at this
point and that indeed is the case
if you look at who are number one swing
voters
and number two who is undecided right
now
what you find is that the undecideds and
swing voters tend to be
younger centrist to center right less
engaged in politics
they aren't actually paying attention so
for example
72 percent of voters who are 65 or older
have decided for sure they know who
they're going to vote for
among 18 to 29 year olds only 47
were decided as of a few weeks ago
that's crazy but it makes sense
in from the standpoint of if you don't
know that much about what's going
on you're more likely to say i don't
know who i'm going to vote for
or whether i'm going to vote it is
people who are paying less attention
it is people who are less informed if
you are remotely informed
and you are a likely voter you voted
before or you're sure that you're going
to vote
it's tough to be undecided right now
we've had almost four years now
of impossibly dramatic differences
between what donald trump has done and
how he has governed
and what a joe biden presidency would
mean
to the united states now the other
question about undecideds is a lot of
undecideds
don't think it's that important whether
one candidate or the other candidate
wins in other words
when you ask all voters
whether it matters who wins 82
to 92 percent say that it matters
when you ask these swing and undecided
voters
does it matter who wins only two-thirds
believe that it matters so
you start to put together a picture of
the undecided voter tends to be younger
ideologically they are moderate to
center right
they aren't paying much attention and
they don't think that the
consequences actually matter that much
that makes sense
if you fall under those categories it
follows logically i don't agree with
those points of view
but it follows logically that you might
say
maybe maybe trump may be biden uh those
who are politically engaged
have overwhelmingly been decided for a
long time those who
have voted in the past have been
overwhelmingly decided for a long time
and um in terms of issues one other
interesting tidbit
is that people who are still undecided
today or as of about
two weeks ago not only are they more
uninformed
they tend to vote based on their gut
feeling of how the economy is doing
and their gut feeling more generally
that
tracks sadly with someone
who could be bamboozled essentially
tricked into voting for donald trump and
that's what's
very very scary and why i am repeating
and hammering on and harping on we need
every vote
we've got to run up the vote in the blue
states we've got to get as many possible
votes
in red states even if they are states
that biden will certainly lose
don't assume anything whatsoever because
gut feeling about the economy is exactly
who's being targeted when trump says
biggest job growth in one month ever
well yeah after record losses right
those are the folks that go i don't know
it just kind of sounds like things are
pretty good
the stock market looks okay this is why
they pour money into the stock market
to reach those exact voters
hey david donald trump famously said he
could shoot people on fifth avenue and
not lose any support
what would it take for trump's base to
abandon him
so i've said before would trump's
base abandon him if he insulted them if
he said my base is filled with
just trash losers i'd never be caught
dead with
i still think even in that case a lot of
trump voters would say
he wasn't insulting me he met somebody
else he didn't mean me
when he talked about his supporters that
he hates i still
don't think that attacking his own base
would get a large number of trump
supporters to abandon him
however i do believe there are people
who would abandon trump if he loudly
came out
in favor of uh women's right to choose
an abortion if it's right for them
donald trump has
maintained this absurd unbelievable lie
that even though he was pro-choice his
entire life
until he was 68 years old that when he
was in his late 60s
he met a kid and he liked the kid and
the kid's mom
said you know i thought about having an
abortion but i decided not to
trump claims that was an awakening
moment for him
where he said i've got to be against
abortion it's an obvious lie
trump clearly is pro-choice it wouldn't
be shocking to me if trump has paid for
abortions for some of his mistresses it
wouldn't surprise me
i do think that there's a part of
trump's base the evangelical voters
where if trump said hey you know what
this right to life stuff
the march for life that i spoke at no
i'm pro-choice
i do think a lot of those uh
anti-abortion
uh voters would abandon donald trump but
the reality is
it's not a huge part of trump's base
evangelicals aren't really his base
they came to him after mostly supporting
i think it was ted cruz
and others in 2016. they went to trump
when the options were trump or hillary
and they certainly
weren't going to be voting for hillary
clinton i really don't know
what it would take for trump's real base
to abandon him
i i actually think they would be in
denial
no matter what and they would support
him
if trump came out and was loudly
anti-gun maybe
some of his base would abandon him but
even then trump has said
some relatively anti-gun things
but then he'll come back and say joe
biden will cancel the second amendment
and it's kind of like a choose your own
adventure i like this thing trump said
so i'm going to believe that that's his
real position
i really can't think of anything trump
could do
to get the bulk of his real base
to abandon him i want to hear from you
is there something he could do
am i on to something with the gun idea
is baby the abortion
issue bigger for more of his base than
just the evangelicals that i'm conceding
let me know what you think we've got a
great bonus show for you today
the bonus show is available to all of
our
members and all of our patrons
contributing at the five dollar a month
level
okay go to joinpakman.com we have a
coupon code
2020 now it'll save you 66
grab a membership you'll get instant
access to the bonus show
or make a pledge over at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow and you will also get
instant access
otherwise that's it for this week i'll
see you next week and remember not only
five new shows next week
not only five new bonus shows next week
tuesday night
september 29th 8 30 pm eastern time
5 30 p.m pacific the first debate
between donald trump and joe biden we
will be live
on youtube twitch and facebook i hope to
see you there
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's
sponsor is blinkist the app that lets
you read or listen
to an entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video